and welcome to Hannity and tonight mob
rule left-wing intimidation harassment
is once again fashionable inside the
modern extreme Democratic Socialist
Party after first ignoring and excusing
and in some cases even openly being
supportive of the 574 violent riots in
the summer of 2020 dozens dead thousands
of cops injured billions in property
damage people like Kamala Harris
promoting a bail fund of Minnesota
praising the LAPD and the defunding
efforts there and then of course
hypocritically spending every waking
moment of every day obsessively
condemning the riot on January 6th and
of course ignoring the core issue of why
Nancy Pelosi and mayor Muriel Bowser
fail to make use of the up to twenty
thousand National Guard troops that
Donald Trump had authorized as required
by law two days prior to keep the peace
as also requested by the Capitol Police
Chief repeatedly that Democrats are now
reversing Course once again and they are
supporting acts of political violence as
we speak far left agitators they're
trying to harass intimidate U.S Supreme
Court Justices and coerce them into
saving Roe v Wade it is a disgusting
repulsive despicable attempt to destroy
the independence of our nation's
Judiciary and the silence and the tacit
approval from the Biden Administration
and Joe Biden and Democrats frankly
that's equally repulsive this week
Justice Alito and his family they were
forced to flee their home after rioters
published alito's address and then made
plans to show up at his front door by
the way they showed up coming up our own
Sarah Carter will join us live from the
scene of a so-called demonstration that
just took place outside of alito's home
but sadly it's not just Justice Alito
over the weekend multiple Supreme Court
Justices and their families were
targeted at their own homes by
pro-abortion an activists let me be
clear this is never okay all of our
public officials both sides of the aisle
must be safe must be protected from
political violence and intimidation
because it's never acceptable on this
show we condemned all of the rioting all
574 riots in the summer of 2020 we
condemn violence on January the 6th I
did it real time on my own radio show
and that night on this show and now we
condemn the less violence against the
Supreme Court and pro-life Americans
everywhere over the weekend in Wisconsin
the headquarters of a pro-life group was
attacked a Molotov cocktail was thrown
through a window into an office causing
considerable damage and look at your
screen this threatening message was
spray painted on the building quote if
abortions aren't safe and you aren't
either a church in Colorado also defaced
by pro-abortion vandals and in New York
St Patrick's Cathedral was surrounded by
protesters hurling insults at anyone who
went inside and in Los Angeles writers
dressed as handmaids stormed into a
Catholic Church service shouting
profanities and pro-abortion rhetoric
and in Washington D.C two Catholic
churches on Capitol Hill requested extra
police presence after one left-wing
group threatened to quote burn the
Eucharist now naturally many Democrats
their friends the media mob they're
applauding this kind of violence I guess
they only are con condemned violence if
they can tie it somehow to something
Republican or conservative in a
statement the Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi applauded these so-called
protesters for using their righteous
anger to March and to mobilize in front
of Justice's houses and get this one
reporter explicitly called for more
violence tweeting a link to the
Wisconsin attack along with the caption
quote more of this may these people
never know a moment of peace or safety
until they out in the ground and
meanwhile the wannabe politician in
California called for Kavanaugh's home
and all of his possessions that they'd
be burned in front of him
rhetoric on TV was even worse take a
look violence is always over the line
but the real questions and conversations
today about protests outside Supreme
Court Justices houses particularly
Justice Kavanaugh
um where do you think that line is I
think for a lot of people the a
conversation about civility feels like
it misses the mark when constitutional
rights that you believe that you had for
over 50 years are about to be overturned
I mean I suppose if the justices don't
like the first amendment they could just
drive to another state where the
legislature has determined that the
constitutional right to privacy applies
right I mean that is what they're
telling women to do if they want to
control their own bodies right all of
these things that we you know say might
happen if abortion gets banned if
abortion becomes illegal they do happen
this isn't a theory we don't need to
speculate we have actual facts that can
inform what happens if Rose overturned
abortion's not getting banned then it's
not going to be illegal that is a big
lie we'll get to that in a second now
believe it or not it actually gets worse
one deranged person over at msdnc saying
she'd like to make love to the Supreme
Court leaker and then joyfully abort the
fetus we'll play that disturbing clip
coming up but maybe worst worst of all
for more than a week the White House
completely utterly refused to condemn
what is the stalking and the outright
intimidation and doxing of Supreme Court
Justices listen to Jen sake repeatedly
excusing and supporting the protests at
the homes of Supreme Court Justices
where they have children and they have
friends and loved ones and neighbors
really you support this Joe take a look
do you think the progressive activists
that are now planning protests outside
some of the justices houses are extreme
peaceful protest no peaceful protest is
not extreme some of these justices have
young kids but their neighbors are not
all public figures so but would the
president think about waiving off
activists that want to go into
residential neighborhoods in Virginia
and Maryland uh Peter look I think our
view here is that peaceful protest
there's a long history in the United
States and the country of that so if he
doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the Supreme Court or outside
someone's private residence I don't have
an official U.S government position on
where people protest
imagine if conservatives started giving
out the addresses of prominent liberal
Democrats and and saying go protests in
front of their house do it peacefully
that'd be okay after a weekend of
violence sake was forced to issue this
tepid statement the president strongly
believes in the constitutional right to
protest but that should never include
violence threats or vandalism judges
perform an incredibly important function
in our society and they must be able to
do their jobs without concern for their
personal safety so why don't you tell
your supporters Joe to stay away from
their private homes and Jen what about
the so-called protesters stalking now
Supreme Court Justices at home care to
say anything about that apparently not
take a look you decide you suggested
that peacefully protesting outside the
homes of of judges and Supreme Court
Justices uh is part of the freedom of
expression and partisan what we do in
the United States but there's a law in
Virginia that actually prohibits protest
outside private residence even when it's
done peacefully so I'm wondering if any
sort of demonstrations outside private
homes might run involved with that law
and other laws of like another person's
country we're certainly not suggesting
anyone break any laws I would note that
the president's view has long been and I
tweeted this earlier this morning and
repeated and made a number of these
comments last week as well that violence
threats and and intimidation have no
place in political discourse and I'm
sure if something happened you'd
probably call it an Insurrection right
Jen do you really think uh do you really
care that Supreme Court Justices are
getting stalked harassed intimidated
this way do you think that you care
about churches being vandalized as we
witnessed this weekend imagine if we
flip the script imagine if conservatives
were stalking harassing liberal Supreme
Court Justices which they never should
do could you imagine the outrage imagine
the hysteria the hypocrisy is off the
charts here and of course Democrat rats
they're all Hypocrites because they have
almost no principles they were virtually
silent with 574 riots in the summer of
2020 but they do want to talk about the
one right because they can use it for
political purposes and think about this
for several years Democrats tried to
weaponize your government and force all
Americans to get vaccinated then boosted
and boosted again even though we had
breakthrough cases millions of Americans
lost their jobs because of that mandate
Millions more were turned away from
restaurants and stores and shut out my
body my choice didn't seem to exist to
the left when it came to vaccines that
same principle well we're not going to
apply that to abortion still at the end
of the day abortion will be legal across
the country all the hysteria all the
hyperbole is false even if Roe v Wade is
overturned so the idea that row if if
row is overturned that it will somehow
end abortion in America is now the big
Democratic lie democracy rats need a
good distraction for the midterms a way
to drive out turnout and excite their
base and their radical bases lapping it
up and I fear this can go back from bad
to worse hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else